waiting on its first mover in an  industry like Wine Library TV buzz or  less social channel like Instagram  Facebook Twitter which all have so many  people on them now how do you go about  breaking through the noise talent you  know I'm excite you know limits yeah you  know what I'm excited I'm excited  because I have a lot of respect for this  room  there's a lot of talent in this room  just because you weren't first doesn't  mean you can't be best like now remember  best comes in to fold that's why I made  that point if you're actually great at  what you do for a living that's the only  part of it  you have to be great at communicating it  in the way it's communicated to that  like you have to you have to understand  angles and pictures or what works in  video or how to use hashtags to be  discovered when nobody knows who you are  they both matter but shouldn't you put  in the work if you get the benefit